[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis wels
heute gibt es ein leckeres kochen rezept
eigentlich wollte ich gerade was anderes
wären aber dann habe ich apple und
rhabarber in meinem kühlschrank entdeckt
und ich dachte mir ich mache einen
streuselkuchen
also machen wir jetzt einen blechkuchen
mit erdbeeren rhabarber ich werde damit
dazu einen quark öl teig machen macht
streusel noch dazu und im prinzip sind
an vier komponenten einmal die streusel
der quark öl teig die fruchtige füllung
und danach so etwas ähnliches wie
pudding aber aus quark es sieht jetzt
aus als wären viele zutaten aber am ende
sind gar nicht so viele also ich hatte
bei mir alles im vorrat erdbeer
rhabarber müsste vielleicht noch dazu
kaufen aber die sind ja momentan in der
saison starten
tun wir jetzt tun wir mit den sträußen
ich nehme dafür 250 gramm mehl 125 gramm
kalte butter 125 gramm zucker eine prise
salz und vanille extrakt und hier habe
ich auch schon mal die fruchtbildung
gerichtet dafür nehme ich nämlich
rhabarber erdbeeren etwas stärke und den
extrakt für die streusel gebe ich
einfach alle zutaten in der schüssel
die können sie entweder mitten im weg
sagt zubereiten oder mit den händen oder
einem handrührgerät das salz noch ein
und zucker und vanille
ich liebe einfach streusel ich nehme so
ein tag so hacker damit kann man die
butter nämlich schönste hacken und jetzt
einfach verbinden bis sich die streusel
gebildet haben gleich nämlich noch die
hände dazu aber am anfang
passt das so ganz gut denn dann kann ich
die brutto so ein bisschen zerkleinern
und dann habe ich es gleich so ein
einfacher wenn die butter seien klein
genug ist nämlich einfach die hände dazu
nein
jetzt hat es doch den fertigen suchen
was könnte ich gleich mal was geben
kannst du die schüssel kalt stellen ich
muss lieber selber sonst landest du
mehrere habe ich gesehen
[Musik]
kann ich die vorstellung zu bereiten
die erdbeeren können die entweder
viertel nacht in würfel schneiden oder
eben schreiben
das glaube ich schnell zu entscheiden
[Musik]
samira hier kannst du weitermachen kann
es so schön in scheiben schneiden ohne
dich zu schneiden
wir haben ja einfach durchdrücken und
nicht ganz schon mal den rabatten wenn
es zu voll wird genau jetzt hier drauf
genau einfach drauf absetzen und zack
kannst du das auch aber schnell mal
einfach so
und oben nicht so viel wegschneiden also
immer schneidet eigentlich nur ein
bisschen damit man so die fäden abziehen
kann man von der anderen seite anderer
seite kommen bei mir
ich setze das messer an und dann ziehe
ich es einfach nur ab und jetzt abziehen
guck mal hier ansetzen
jetzt sieht es so hoch und die heute
praktisch nur noch nicht mehr messer
komplett durch also theoretisch geht es
auch genau mit einem stumpfen messer
oben
man muss nur einmal unter die die schale
kommen
hippchen rhabarber einfach noch fein
schneiden und das gestellte gewicht sind
jetzt hier 750 gramm 750 gramm auch
erdbeeren also einfach eins zu eins
wenn ihr das ganze jetzt ohne erdbeeren
mach doch sondern nur rhabarber
verwendet würde ich auf jeden fall ein
bisschen zucker dazugeben
aber hier bekomme ich als die süße durch
die erdbeeren
jetzt kommt gleich mal ein
standardspruch joschka noch eine etwas
größere schüssel dem was wunderbar zu
erdbeeren und rhabarber passt ist
vanilla also entweder ein bisschen
vanille zucker oder wandel extract aber
wandel extrakt ist halt viel viel
intensiver weil es nämlich echte vanille
es da noch die stärke zum binden
die nehme ich jetzt wegen der erdbeere
weil die erdbeere einfach viel
feuchtigkeit enthält
ich glaube ich würde das jetzt gut so
denn nun aber wird es schwierig neben
eine größere schüssel
ich mache einfach in zeitlupe
hier ich mache sie eine echtzeit slomo
auch wie das riecht oh mein gott ich
könnte das jetzt gerade löffeln würde
ich aber nicht tun weil der awaro ist
was ich die massen hier kurz stehen und
kam noch die zwei übrigen komponenten zu
bereiten
zum einen die quarkcreme für zum drauf
klecksen wie so eine art pudding und zum
anderen inc wackelt die cvag reden
nämlich 250 gramm quark 31 gramm zucker
25 gramm stärke und etwas von den
extrakt und jetzt könnte ich hier
einfach alle zutaten vermischen in einer
schüssel dick genug ist werden wir
gleich sehen
immer wenn ich jetzt ein löffel nicht so
ablegt muss ich an den sturm ihr denken
weil da immer nur die löffel ablage so
hier zucker stärke zurückfinden in den
teig kommt keine wandel auf
nein auch kein poker und jetzt hören wir
euch noch ein feuer fertig perfekt
komponente 3 ist fertig und jetzt kommt
der teig den macht man nämlich zum
schluss da backpulver enthalten ist und
sobald der teig nämlich gleich gemacht
ist jetzt schon aufs blech für den teig
nämlich 250 gramm quark zweier 200 gramm
milch 70 km öl 500 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel backpulver 125 gramm zucker
etwas salz und zitrone abrieb und einen
quark öl teig ist wirklich super schnell
gemacht ich habe jetzt auch den ofen
schon vorgeheizt der sollte jetzt auch
schon bereit sein
ich nehme jetzt erstmal hier die
flüssigen oder halter feuchten zutaten
quarks und immer wenn ich quark auf
meinem blog oder in der app stehen habe
nämlich immer magerquark und wenn ich
einen anderen wagen im sahnequark zum
beispiel dann schreibe ich dazu dann die
eier milch und jetzt kann ich die
zutaten schon mal ganz kurz verrühren
im quark öl teig kann man eigentlich
nichts falsch machen außer man kann zu
lange hin
aber da ist wirklich super schnell also
wenn es ganz ganz schnell gehen muss und
ihr keine lust oder keine zeit auch
früher öl teig oder auch früher teig
biscuit oder andere teil gehabt könnte
denen immer super zu bereiten
wenn man muss wirklich nur die flüssigen
zutaten erst verrühren und dann die
trockenen dazu und fertig als ich ihr
mehl und backpulver zog auf salzburgs
krone und jetzt noch kurz verrühren bis
sich alles verbunden hat
perfekt guck mal das ist so ein 60
sekunden teig und das habe ich hier
schon mal ein backblech
das stelle ich jetzt auf 25 x 30 cm 1
ihr könnt wenn ihr jetzt die größe nicht
habt oder kleiner oder größer backen
wohl zb ein ganzes blech ganz einfach in
meiner app alles umrechnen lassen gibt
die backform größe ein
ihr könnt auch im runden kuchen backen
und zb 20 cm im durchmesser eingeben und
dann rechnen sich die zutaten
automatisch in der apple hat ihr müsst
nicht unbedingt diese größe nehmen
da kommt jetzt zuerst der teig rein wenn
er nicht ganz so schön geschmeidig ist
einfach noch ein bisschen milch
dazugeben
aber bei mir passt das jetzt so das soll
jetzt auch nicht so flüssig sein
[Musik]
wenn ihr in etwas flacher haben wollt
dann könnt ihr den bug rahmen einfach
größer einstellen
das wird jetzt schon so ein höherer
kuchen hab ich glaub ich finds gut ich
mache jetzt doch 30 30 denn da geht
immer mega gut auf schwaben trick
einfach größer gemacht der moral wäre
stolz auf mich dann könnt ihr hier jetzt
die quarkcreme darüber träufeln
einfach super klecksen dazwischen dann
die früchte und die streusel obendrauf
ich hab jetzt doch nicht alle früchte
genommen ich schreibe euch auf jeden
fall die geänderte menge in die app denn
sind zufrieden aber die koche ich gleich
ein dann habe ich noch nicht so eine art
komplott aber mit bis hin zum jetzt noch
die streusel drauf und dann dass der
kuchen in den backofen
[Musik]
der kuchen ist jetzt gebacken er hat
tatsächlich länger als eine stunde
backen müssen denn es ist ja auch viel
macht jetzt haben abkühlen lassen und
jetzt lese ich ihnen hier kurz raus
bringt den müll weg verschenkt machte er
läuft gleich wieder zurück was ich
schneide ich wirklich letzte schnee
nicht so viel okay nicht so viel schnee
aber ein bisschen noch muss natürlich
sein roboter ist die große hoffnung so
dass man so ein bisschen hier die ecke
noch bisschen perfekt kommt dann kann
ich schon mal ein stück für euch
anschneiden
dann dürft ihr zwei probieren drei
mädels im video
das papier ist also ich finde ihn lecker
vor allem passen die streusel gut so
denn süßen erdbeeren mit dem rhabarber
gern und er ist nicht so süß
deswegen kann man ruhig noch ein
glitzernder schnee drauf machen oder
puderzucker
also probieren gerne aus dass die kirche
eine führung vor sich hin
und das rezept gibt es wie immer in
meiner app oder auf dem blog bis zum
nächsten mal
ihr könnt ja mal schreiben was euer
lieblings report mit erdbeere oder mit
rhabarber schmeckt euch der chor in
[Musik]